welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Loki
season 2 episode 2 all the Marvel Easter
eggs interesting film making choices
complex timeline logic and clues for
where this season seems to be going I
got you covered folks and huge thanks to
everyone who spent part of their past
week with us by watching our episode one
breakdown our reaction any other video
we released this week about Loki it's
just the show it's themes and the corner
of the MCU it is establishing just mean
so much to me and I'm just grateful to
be able to share my observations with
you okay after an updated Marvel Studios
title card that reminder includes he who
remains from the season 1 finale as a
citadel elevator doors open into his
office and added Mis minutes stalling
with those fake records with sylv and
ren Slayer in season 1 episode 5 episode
2 opens in London 1977 which the lower
third title confirms is the sacred
timeline a contrast for the episode one
post credit scene that clarified that
Sylvia and Brock in Oklahoma is a
branched timeline so here we are looking
at a part of history as the TVA planned
it in normal MCU history there is always
been an actor in the 70s named Brad wolf
in a movie called zaniac starring him in
the opening shot on the left is a London
news stand with the daily Inquirer
spelled with an E not an I like the
British tabloid The Inquirer sign on the
far left prints a headline dreams what
do yours say about you we are seeing X5
live out his dream life here on the
sacred timeline and for him his dreams
tell him that he is a narcissistic prick
all of our characters this episode are
tempted to live out their dreams or roll
up their sleeves and do the Dirty Work
to keep the universe from imploding now
if you're feeling a bit of whiplash in
this opening scene with Mobius and Loki
already wearing '70s movie premiere
tuxedo costumes yeah this all happens
pretty fast they were just looking for
Sylvie and x5's temp pad going offline
as their best lead since Doc and X5 were
pursuing Sylvie but it still feels like
a scene is missing that you know maybe
would have shown Mobius and Loki finding
this dat on the sacred timeline from the
TVA Chrono monitor Bay and then deciding
to go there but there is no scene like
that and they said that there was no
scenes that were reshot for this season
of Loki but you know maybe there should
have been in this case but if you watch
the scene closely a line was added with
Owen Wilson dubbing in some Exposition
in the post-production step but you said
you wanted to find Sylvie right with
docs and X5 not responding this our only
lead there are some fun Easter eggs on
the posters here first is a poster for
the 1974 Herby Rides Again a sequel to
the 70s Disney franchise and all of the
descriptions of Herby in this poster
apply to Loki in this sequel season he's
daring he's playful he's romantic he's
athletic and he's defiant Loki Rides
Again next is an amazing Easter egg a
Bollywood movie poster for a movie
starring Kingo camil Nani's Eternal from
eternals who does what Brad wolf is now
doing living a dream life as a movie
star this poster was actually on kingo's
private jet on the far left in the
eternals film The movie is Saro kutra or
in English son of SOS we also saw Kingo
posters in Hollywood in the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special and then on a
sign for this leapold theater it boasts
a new and improved Cinema snack bar with
hot popcorn orange juice juice cartons
and ice cream and then at the bottom tea
and snacks offered at intermission
beneath that is a fully ridiculous
poster for a fictional movie called
phone Ranger perhaps a play on The Lone
Ranger with the tagline criminals he's
got your number starring Charles the
bald Rick Dune Lorenzo mver and Victor D
eliwood produced by Goodman Productions
which is the same company and production
team that made zaniac the phone Rangers
head is a red phone and his chest emblem
is a phone keypad his sidekick uses a
corded phone as a weapon I guess you
could draw some TVA connections here
like the mystery ringing phone of
episode one and the idea of
anthropomorphizing a face into a phone
instead of a clock like Miss minutes
does but this Premiere is for a horror
movie called zaniac which according to
the Marquees Stars Brad wolf and George
Ethan Walker Steven Allen and Leah M
Jensen it looks like the artist of this
poster use Raphael Cal's likeness to
render this monster but zaniac is
actually detail for Marvel Comics a Thor
villain from Thor 319 in 1982 introduced
as a swarm of demonic creatures from the
dark dimension that possess a host and
gives them a blood lust and a desire to
kill women which it does for the actor
Brad wolf while he is shooting a slasher
film at the University of Chicago in the
same site where they conducted the test
for the Manhattan Project watch
Oppenheimer goes into that and while he
was dressed in a costume as this goofy
movie villain whose name was a zaniac he
gets possessed by the Swarm and caught
in a radioactive blast you know
University of Chicago students don't go
under the football field but years later
in Marvel comic zaniac returns in 1986
is Thor 371 372 when Thor teams up with
TV a agent justice peace to prevent the
zaniac from starting a World War so I
think that's really the reference point
here with Loki teaming up with the TVA
to intervene with Brad wolf as Brad wolf
is living out to the timeline as he was
supposed to live it I guess we should
assume that X5 pruned his sacred
timeline self and took his place maybe
doing this months ago to allow himself
to grow out this haircut now I've
compared this season of Loki to The
Matrix and X5 is absolutely an analog
for Cipher Joe Pano's character who
betrays the other humans in a deal with
the agents to plug himself self back
into the simulation and specifically
makes this request and don't want to be
rich you know someone
important like an actor so in the
theater Lobby we hear a disco rendition
of Natalie Holtz Loki theme music a
reporter asks Brad are the Bridget BAU
rumors true Bridget BAU was a French
actress and sex symbol in the 50s
through the 70s but she withdrew from
the spotlight in 1973 so this would be
Brad wolf kind of canoodling with her to
bring her back out of reti Mobius asks
if there will be a zaniac 2 and I just
love this gag of having more famous
actors pretending to be the less famous
face at a public event my favorite
example of this gag being Steven
Soderberg shot in Oceans 11 as Topher
Grace and Joshua Jackson came out of the
nightclub and got mobbed by fans while
George cludy and Brad Pit walked by all
these people unnoticed and given some
like annoyed side eye by some of those
fans I love food a good meal is a movie
for your mouth but I particularly love
it when it's delicious and delivered
straight to me and that's what cook
Unity is all about you know Mouth movies
cook Unity is a first chef to Consumer
platform that delivers freshly prepared
pre-selected meals right to your door
weekly cook Unity is basically a
pipeline from your home to a diverse
group of talented chefs that cook
delicious inventive meals fresh everyday
in Regional micro kitchens not Warehouse
production facilities and the meals they
make are so good there's no artificial
ingredients the meat is humanely raised
and cook Unity chefs use organic
ingredients whenever possible there's
meals for everyone including options for
vegan paleo gluten-free diets all
covering a wide range of Cuisines you
could be eating Ruben Garcia's crispy
tilapia one night classic Italian
meatballs from Chef Dustin Taylor the
next night and then Kickstart your
weekend with booji be and Bop from Chef
Esther Choy and you got to see my first
cook Unity meal so this week we got
shrimp and smoked and dewy sausage
jambalaya jambalaya M oh really good so
good all the meals are delivered fully
cooked so all you have to do is heat
them up no more cleanup no more meal
planning all you have to to do is set up
your Weekly subscription if you want to
pause skip a week or cancel it's super
easy to do so go to cook unity.com en
rockstars 50 or click the link in the
description below and use my code in
rockstars 50 to get 50% off your first
order of cookunity meals to try them out
for yourself so Brad scampers out of the
side door and tries to use his modified
temp Pad but B15 intercepts oh my God
it's Brad wolf can I gag your autograph
anything for a B15 uses a young Dopey
American girl accent here in London and
even though Wy mosaku is a British
actress and would be right at home
playing an English girl she uses an
American accent here because it's Brad
she's trying to woo here and he would
probably be more into an American
Tourist B15 wears this TVA orange color
the lights of the alleyway bathe them
all in Orange she just looks awesome but
when Brad initially spills out into the
street a few punk rockers are leaning
against that back wall in the background
these are the ones that Loki later
illusion projects to fool Brad so this
would be the moment that he clocks them
stores them in his mind for later ly
blasts Brad down some steps there's a
pile of newspapers and Mattress that
would have been convenient for Brad to
land on but no he lands on cold heart
pavment now if you look at the sign this
is strand Lane and I actually mapped out
this exact spot in the cing garden
neighborhood of London and these steps
are the Siri steps which is adjacent to
an easy toiss London historical
curiosity what was called a Roman bath
according to Victorian londoners but
this just dates back to the early 17th
century by the way I am obsessed with
the city of London I actually lived in
this neighborhood in summer 2008 is
filled with World Easter eggs like this
and I am as unsufferable on London
walking tours as I am on YouTube now
they almost get run over by a Miller and
King Classic Range Rover and then X5
uses what looks like a prisoner time
twister to escape but rather than it
being on his neck collar he wears it on
his wrist like a watch X5 twists right
back to that base of the Sur steps on
strand Lane where Loki knocked him on
his ass before X5 then runs into a gang
of punk rockers but he look closely some
of them are mods based on those bikes
that they're riding so mods you remember
are the London gangs that they based the
tattoo Queen gang on remember from the
book of bth and it made everyone really
mad while those mods were around mostly
in the 50s and 60s there was a mod
Revival period in the late 70s so it
would make sense that they're here now
behind them on the street is the pub
called the hat and ton which is in a
different part of London the coven
Garden this is on hat and wall and hat
and place thus the hat and ton Loki
reveals himself as an illusion
projection and swipes the Twister off
x5's
wrist you quit with the magic and fight
fair oh yeah I like the camera
trick They Do by cutting away from Loki
and closeup back to X5 yelling at him
and in that reverse shot of X5 they
already have Tom hon standing in the
background from the beginning of that
shot so Loki's duplicates close in on X5
as he backs toward a wall with less is
enough written on it which is ironic
because Loki is totally using some
Overkill here meanwhile on the wall
behind Loki is graffiti reading piss off
so it's kind of like their backdrops are
shouting at each other this is enough oh
piss off Loki's horned Shadows grab X5
and I know I bringing up 1990s ghost a
lot because I just watched it it's like
one of my favorite movies but this is a
lot like when the demon Shadows come to
life and grab the damn to drag them off
to hell and to make that sound effect
they use the sounds of babies crying and
then stretched it out lowered it and
makes it sound so creepy so Loki asks a
little over the top don't you think all
the shadow
play I thought it was spot on yeah we
all assume Loki is Middle projection but
he's actually on the right he's never
where you think he'll be so D90 and B15
escort X5 through the TVA and they
passed this poster that instructs when
prompted take deep breaths and in the
bottom left corner it reads enhanced
conversations with variants such
interesting advice for these TVA
interrogators as a center section of
this episode explores Mobius and Loki's
interrogation tactics on X5 tactics that
he as a TV Hunter would know how to
resist and counteract including an
ability and an inability we'll see
inside that time Cube to take deep
breaths movus and Loki approach OB in
the RNA and he mutters to himself got to
weave these two wirs together me this NE
and T yes weaving cords together tightly
is also physically what the tempor Loom
is supposed to do with timelines now
behind his desk you can see a popcorn
bucket so popcorn was he at that leapold
theater zenc Premiere also there's a box
labeled mullard which is a British
electronics parts manufacturer that was
founded in the early 20th century OB
offers to look into x5's temp Pad but he
asks do you think this is a higher
priority than preventing a temporal
meltdown I love KIU Quan's delivery here
because while this line could be read as
sarcastically there is not a hint of
attitude in his voice instead he just
flips them his TVA handbook and notice
every time we see him handle it he flips
it elegantly in fact I didn't fully
appreciate enough the smooth
over-the-shoulder toss and grab from
kiwan to Tom Heston while they were in
motion and perfectly hitting all their
complex dialogue in that long take last
episode never forget that kiwi Quan is
great at physical acting in stunts in
fact he worked on the stunt crew of the
200000 X-Men film we have not seen his
full form on the series yet he is going
to fight at some point this season in
fact I really do get the sense that KIU
Kuan is kind of an Angelic entity the
original he remains the OG like Morgan
Freeman and Bruce Almighty and that Obie
here is just kind of tossing them a
hotel nightstand Bible and hinting all
the answers are right here if you were
to just open this book B15 checks in
with Casey who speaks softly thinking
that the ren Slayer Trace is a secret I
like this because every time Owen Wilson
talks on the series he's like
practically whispering but B15 correctly
points out that now that they're in this
existential crisis mode there's no point
in information siloing she reminds us
that Ren Slayer killed C20 referring to
that poor hunter from season 1 who was
kidnapped by Sylvie and gave up the
information on the time people location
in the TVA just a reminder that there is
a difference in the TVA between pruning
which banishes one to the void and
directly killing which would eradicate
one from existence a kendis
spaghettification Casey says with mis
minutes down the analysts are running
traces manually yeah we seeing how
Reliant the TVA was on Miss minutes she
wasn't like a Microsoft Office paperclip
friend but kind of an extension of he
remains ruling unilaterally on which
variants and which branch timelines to
make a move on movus and Loki tried to
unscrew x5's temp pad themselves section
42 should match with the system is that
with the red light cuz we tried that
already we'll try it again the number 42
because media literacy is dead and
everything equals everything everyone
thinks every mention of the number 42 is
a reference to the answer of the great
question and Douglas Adams hit sher's
guide or Miles Morales spider's Universe
number or Jackie Robinson's number or a
number that shows up and everything
everywhere all at once also starring Ki
Quan or the number of the rounds on
Ripley's pulse rival and Aliens as she
was going down the elevator sometimes
it's just a high enough double- digigit
number that screenwriters like to use
kind of like the recurring number 17 in
the MCU and 12 often used as the highest
single syllable number and really I just
think they chose the number 42 cuz it's
pretty amusing that a temp pad would
have at least 42 sections to it Casey
reports that Miss minutes is helping Ren
Slayer and Loki relays that audio
recording that he heard in the past that
RN Slayer and he remains were Partners
so we're getting a sense of a love
triangle at the heart of the Season he
remains burning RN Slayer for some
reason and he remains other side piece
Miss minutes as a fellow spurned ex with
his two girlfriends joining forces
like two ghosts of girlfriend's past a
theory that we've been chewing on is
that Mis minutes may be part of Ren
slayer's mind or memory or Soul or
Consciousness that was extracted from
her body and contained in a separate
animated shell like the second half of
Ren Slayers by Camal mind in Tuesday's
video we talked about the possibility
that RN Slayer could have been Kang's
female variant the way Sylvie was Loki's
variant so if/ win RN Slayer Mis minutes
unite and share notes they could amount
to a full Kang variant of equal threat
or even greater threat than he remains
B15 says about Miss minutes she really
is full of surprises yeah it kind of
sounds like she was about to say she
really is fing annoying the glass panel
of mob's cubicle has words he's written
station detail cards time detail cards
error details and then some graph with a
stair step increase there but on the
x-axis of course is time so they
interrogate X5 and you'll notice this
room is all orange orange is often
considered the most irritating color
visually for interior design at least
when it's in an overwhelm Welling amount
Loki tells X5 that there are lives at
stake which X5 throws back in his
face you're just trying to make up for
all the terrible awful you've done
in your life you pathetic little man
just a reminder that l1130 is not the
Loki who went through Thor the Dark
World or Ragnarok or Infinity War but
rather this one he killed 80 people in 2
days he's adopted but since Loki has
already made peace with that life he
lets X5 go on see everything you and
Sylvie have ever done to try to help has
only ever made it worse ooh X5 going
after Sylvie pisses Loki off because
Loki knows that this Sylvie from a young
age was really a victim of the TVA so
he's ready to tell X5 to keep his girl's
name out his mouth X5 notices that lok's
trigger is when he brings up the women
in his life so he does it again you just
make everything
worse for Mobius for
B15 for your mother o not frer don't
talk about about guys moms X5 calls Loki
a loser and a villain and Loki Embraces
being a loser calling back he in sylv's
conversation in season 1 episode 4 do
you think that what makes a Loki a
Loki is the fact that we're destined to
lose Mobius eases attention with a knock
knock joke who's there Brad Brad who
that's show
this I think the funniest thing about it
is just that little laugh that Owen
Wilson gives afterwards but Mobius is
thinking that he can catch more flies
with honey but that backfires as X5 gets
under his skin questioning who Mobius
was back on the sacred timeline who he
left behind making me wonder if Mobius
might have had a co-pilot while he was
riding that jet ski and instead Mobius
gives X5 the Mr Jada pinket Smith
treatment open-handed nowhere man you're
a ah in there you heard them calling
each other a nowhere man which is an
interesting term now that we got the
cosmic MCU in the idea of someone being
AER man with a K meaning a refugee who
would find himself starting over inside
of a skull afterwards Mobius says nope
he didn't get under my skin he got under
your skin yeah suddenly Mobius tracing
the word skin in the dust bear some new
meaning so they make it to the autom mat
a green room with only one entrance at
the end of this remote hallway that kind
of looks like it's just past the RNA no
one else is in here but there is a whole
wall full of cases of slices of key lime
pie which I must say is normally not
this shade of green the walls of this
automat contain this poster that reads
one slice per week bartering for extra
tokens is forbidden $7 minutes is
sufficient tokens have the TVA Employees
been getting weekly tokens and had no
idea what they were for or are these
just tokens for any food that they could
purchase at the cafeteria and didn't
know that they could also be used here
at the automat and yeah there's that
number 17 coming back and sure since we
did this for 42 let's play this game
with 17 so 17 was one of the Winter
Soldier activation words 17A was The
Avengers compound storage unit that
contained iron spider armor also
Infinity War tchala ordered to open
Northwest section 17 is there any
significance or is the MCU just an
OverWatch franchise with dozens of films
in common out ities are bound to occur
in 17 it's just kind of like another
weirdly specific prime number that
simultaneously a lot of something but
also not enough of something Loki
recalls the events of 2012's Avengers
you remember that time I was so angry
with my father and my brother I went
down to earth and I held the whole of
New York City hostage with an alien Army
interesting for Loki to now frame it not
as pure ambition but as bitterness he
felt toward Thor and Odin he goes on
tried to use the mindstone on Tony star
and it didn't work so I threw him off
the building I mean let me tell you
something wasn't tactical another
interesting detail because this Loki was
extracted from the year 2012 and back at
that point he must have known that the
scepter contained an infinity stone that
wasn't something any of the Avengers at
that time or the studio or we knew to be
true at least in 2012 Loki also asks
Mobius if he was ever curious about his
sacred timeline life in case it was
something bad and Mobius says that he
could handle something bad but he would
hate it if it were something good which
tells us that Loki can only imagine his
sacred timeline Life as a series of
tragedies losing frigga losing Odin his
own death he can't imagine a happy life
that he would be missing out on because
his life in the TVA with Sylvie has been
the happiest he's ever been when Obie
first enters the loom room he passes a
screen that reads Perpetual sequencer C
and on that screen a few links in a
chain with a flashing Center which may
represent the overwhelmed temporal Loom
on a second computer screen which we see
in close-up it reads interconnector B
displacement b and a bunch of V which ie
would St for variance and we see that
the value for FV is null I don't know
what that means I just wanted to point
that out for you ob's temporal AA reads
as invalid so someone with the right
time Soul fingerprint needs to activate
this if Obie said Miss minutes would
keep this running and he only needed to
run Diagnostics and they need he who
remains aura that could fuel my theory
that Miss minutes is a kind of
derivative of a Kang variant because she
would carry a trace of his Aura in sense
of color palette this episode I just
kind of find it interesting that this
episode swings back and forth between
alarming orange filling the frame to
relaxing seafoam filling the frame
scalding our rods and cones with orange
and then soothing them with seafoam for
round two of x5's interrogation they
wheel in this device that we actually
saw in the end credits montage and all
of these scenes we've seen this vent
hose hanging from the wall and now we
see that it plugs into this thing that
kind of looks like an old school vacuum
or shop back but Loki switches it on and
Mobius does a really good job pretending
like he doesn't want this to happen to
be the good cop that the bad cop locked
out of the room mobus hey
get in here yeah there's his tail he
calls him Brad through the door not X5
to kind of make himself sound like he's
x5's friend that he doesn't want him to
get hurt Loki creates a Time Cube around
the stool and then crushes it and then
forms one around X5 last episode we saw
a poster explaining the timecube
atmosphere and now we know what this
does and it's horrifying I actually love
this textural detail of all the
scratches on this plexiglass like
surface kind of makes it feel tangible
to us the viewer and somewhat creepy as
the scratches might have come from
people desperately trying to claw out of
this or suddenly scratching along the
floor as it shrunk in size and now we
have some context for why this floor is
graded it's for when people trapped
inside this time Cube get crushed down
to viscera and that would ooze down to
the drain we are seeing a slaughter
house killing floor and yeah they really
must have pressed Raphael Cal's arms
against some surface because now we see
his elbow skin pressing against it and
just apologize anyy claustres watching
this episode because it must have been
torture for them the loom room X-Men
doors open again I brought these up last
episode I don't think this is an
intentional cerebra reference or
anything trust me after breaking down
movies and TV shows for seven years x's
and hex's show up everywhere and we
learn how Casey is Star Struck to meet
OB will you sign mine for me of course I
will happy to do it yeah just next to
your picture yeah Obie's picture is in
the TVA guide book I'm telling you for
Mis minutes or he remains to allow or
aoris to retain any public authorship on
any literature inside the walls of the
TVA means that OB has some power that
they cannot override OB might be the OG
the original he remains yet OB cannot
access the loom room without he remains
Aura so they kind of have these checks
and balances on each other X5 takes them
to the McDonald's in Brockton Oklahoma
1982 where the sign reads over 40
billion served in the 1980s McDonald's
would boast how many billions of burgers
they had served but they officially
stopped counting in 1993 so the signage
now simply reads over 99 billion served
you can imagine Sylvie seeing this sign
and thinking after watching billions
upon billions of people die in
apocalyptic Events maybe now I can work
for a service that just serves tens of
billions of people Loki finds Sylvie
inside working the register now having
grown a solid 80s mullet you can also
see that she's wearing ank earrings one
detail I missed from episode one that
many of you pointed out to me in the
comments was that Casey's guided
meditation tape was the same recording
listened to by Steven Grant in moonnight
calm your mind and relax solving puzzles
is a great way to keep your mind awake
so I don't know maybe there will be
further connections between the TBA and
the egyptology of moonnight and we get
some more Orange versus seafoam color
cont here in the parking lot sylv's
orange McDonald's uniform as she sits on
the bed of a green forward Ranger Loki
tells Sylvie that he saw her in his
future but she says that she made sure
that the future wouldn't be written what
Sylvie isn't considering is that maybe
he remains might have wanted her to kill
him that that could have been part of
his original plan that's Loki's
assumption that he remains with telling
the truth that they can't let the TVA go
unfixed he offers even to let her
enchant him so that she can see what is
in his mind something he never wanted
her to be able to do back on lenus this
is a big concession from him the last
time we saw Sylvia enchant something it
was elith when she Enchanted him to see
where the Citadel was at the end of time
and for the second time this episode
mobus Chows down on some pie this time a
McDonald's apple pie to compare to the
key lime pie earlier and I love how X5
is framed perfectly next to the
Hamburglar one of these we an old timey
prison Garb striped uniform whereas X5
is wearing the TVA prison Garb both of
them they're just little burglar Mobius
Coes X5 into talking about the zeniac
it's not scary it's elevated Thriller
all right it's cinema cinema Marvel must
have known this season of Loki would be
dropping around the same time as a
Martin Scorsese movie because the last
time Marty was in the Press circuit it
was 2019 for the Irishman when he
famously pissed off Marvel fans by
saying that the MCU wasn't quote Cinema
but you know what Marty had the last
laugh because uh Marvel apparently
according to the Hollywood Reporter is
on fire right now and killers of the
flower moon is great but the reason X5
has been so jumpy is that they are
currently in a branch timeline and he
knows what general Doc is planning to do
to all these branches which Sylvie and
out of him aomin is a common so Sylvie
tapped something on her hand to make her
McDonald's uniform disenchant back into
the armor she showed up here wearing
after she killed he remains presumably
what she tapped is he remains Tad but
she must have cloaked it to be invisible
on her hand back in the TVA Chrono
monitor Bay the screen shows branches
getting bombed and notice they are all
numbered with codes beginning with 616
we see Branch 61607 K TR 470 bombed
Branch 61611 qy 435 Branch 616 13p e r
O2 like error that's bombed branch 616
44u uq 001 and other 616 coded branches
in the ticker above the TVA is
apparently using the same universe
designation system for the Marvel Comics
in which 616 is considered the main
Marvel Universe number Loki also used
this in season 1 when Loki's film strip
was labeled eth 616 and Multiverse of
Madness established the MCU 616 at least
from Christine Palmer's perspective from
Universe 838 this rightfully drives
Marvel Comics readers nuts because the
MCU film Universe was supposed to be
labeled earth1 199999 and the film
Universe exists as a separate Universe
within the pages of 616 comics
Spider-Man across the spiderverse even
fired a shot by reestablishing the MCU
as Earth 19999 don't even get me I'm
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth
199999 I did a whole video diving into
this debate and I revealed that Kevin
feige actually never said that the MCU
was Earth 199999 that myth was made up
in a Reddit comment and never fact
checked this actually came from a 2008
Source book from a wholly different
division of Marvel from the film studio
so this idea of label in all these
branches 616 something is Marvel Studios
saying that the MCU sacred timeline is
616 and each branch is a subset of 616
but I completely agree with Iman valani
and every Marvel Comics reader who find
this confusing I always say if you want
to call it 6'6 put an asterisk next to
it that says not yet not until after
Secret Wars and we have like X-Men
Fantastic 4 and all the rightful Marvel
lineup in the universe so movus Loki and
Sylvie find General doc Center Hunters
and this remote Command Center this
shooting location is the historic chadam
dockyards in Kent in the UK this was
established in the 16th century
following the reformation and has since
built over 500 ships for the Royal Navy
until it was closed in 1984 in the
background you can actually see the sign
deliu and soner B Beery Dan delu is
Marvel's longtime bfx supervisor who
directed this episode bagland B berer is
actually a shipyard in Norway doc has
rigged up reset charges with temp ads to
bomb Branch timelines something that
Sylvie recognizes because think about it
this is more or less what she did at the
end of episode 2 of Loki season 1
dropping all those reset charges from
The Rock card Superstore except her
charges caused chaos throughout the
timeline Doc is dropping these bombs to
try to clean it all up but the three of
them shut down the operation Sylvia uses
that sword that she used to stab he who
remains Lui uses a pruning stick and he
Chucks it at one hunter from a distance
and then the variants join hands and
finish the job don't overthink it Sylvie
doesn't want Loki to fall in love with
her through this gesture yet notice how
they are always more powerful when they
are joining hands episode two of the
first season ended with Sylvie opening a
Time door and walking through it
trusting Loki to follow her but coming
off as if she didn't care whether or not
he did and that's what Loki does here he
just gives Sylvia one glance and then
turns to walk through the door and
trusts her to make her own choice on
whether or not to follow and she does
but they all watch in horror at dox's
success billions of people being pruned
out of existence the dead timelines turn
the color gray which is a color of the
dust that thanos's victims turn into
when they were erased from existence a
visual effect that Dan delu actually led
the design of and on that screen at the
bottom it says 82 active which makes me
think that there might still be 802
active branches which would still be a
lot for OB to try to manage but earlier
they said that doc successfully pruned
at least 30% of them so doing some math
here 802 overx = 70 over 100 that would
mean that there were originally a total
of
1,146 branches and that at least 343 of
them were pruned 343 different Earths
now our Earth's current population is
7.88 billion so multiply that by 343 of
them that would mean over 2.7 trillion
people were just erased from existence
by General doc but we still see some
orange branches still intact so I assume
that would include the branch timeline
of sylv McDonald's and Brockton but this
pruning of the hay stack has a silver
lining the temporal Loom won't be in as
much of an immediate crisis but they
also have a clear enough signal to lock
onto Ren slayer's temp pad that screen
lists the TVA entity as 22 one/ a
there's a still intact Branch F2 one
branch pruned and then a branch Q2 that
flashes I assume that is the branch that
Ren Slayer is now on but Sylvie says the
TVA is the problem it's broken
it's rotten and she leaves and Loki says
it's harder to stay this episode began
by asking what our dreams say about us
for Sylvie her dreams say that it's
easier to just chill out and eat a Big
Mac than it is to do the hard work and
face a life full of consequences so we
end with Sylvie back in that McDonald's
parking lot her hands folded over her
stomach where she hides he remains temp
pad the trophy that she has no intention
of surrendering we see some photos in
the closing credits that have been
updated to include Brad Wolf's actor
head shot also a photo of Casey and B15
Sylvia the McDonald's Loki and obious in
London and general docks meanwhile the
song playing over the closing credits is
Janice Joplin's Cosmic Blues which
features Janice Joplin starting out slow
time keeps moving on friends they turn
away then she gets more impassionate and
she says I keep moving on but I never
found out why and then Janice Joplin
just goes into her signature scream and
I keep pushing too hard and babe I keep
trying to make it right through another
and then she slows down it says lonely
day oh W and I love how this music
frames Sylvie as an older wiser woman
trying to enjoy her peace and quiet but
then angrily turning on herself as she
hasn't really gotten over anything thank
you so much for watching this breakdown
of Loki episode 2 I'm just blown away
that so many of you care enough to make
these analysis part of your viewing I
appreciate all of you so please hit up
those comments with your thoughts and
theories and be sure to check out our
reaction to this episode and stay tuned
for our sneak peek at episode 3 coming
this Sunday we're actually going to mix
it up with a new rotating guest every
week you can support us by grabbing some
of our exclusive Loki inspired merch
designs over at nerd rot. shop please
subscribe to all three of our channels
in the new rock star Network you can
follow me at eaos and I'll see you next
week bye
[Music]
everybody